welcome to this week's world stories the
harsh conditions of India's coal fields
Thailand's waterways go electric but
first to southern Spain migrants mostly
from Africa have long worked the farms
in under Lucia but their hopes of a
better life are often dashed by harsh
conditions and scarce opportunities
for these illegal migrants the struggle
for survival begins every morning at the
break of dawn at a roundabout near al
meriya they gather and wait hoping to be
hired working in the nearby greenhouses
is their only source of income in a
place where they believed they would
find wealth and freedom those who are
invited into one of these minivans are
the lucky ones social worker Jose Garcia
wants to warn the migrants about
exploitation he and his colleagues from
the Andalusian labor union say illegal
migrants are particularly vulnerable
handing out flyers he wants to inform
them about their rights for one day
you're supposed to earn 46 euros and 72
cents only 8 hours of work these illegal
workers here might not have any
documents but they do have rights we
want to let them know that the Spanish
law is protecting them and about the
minimum wage they're supposed to earn
and the conditions they should demand
but it's hard to demand your rights if
you don't have documentation Mauro from
Mali takes us to what he calls his home
tucked away between the many greenhouses
she shares a flat with seven other farm
workers and is lucky to have electricity
and running water but there's not enough
money to buy proper food he says
leftovers from last night's dinner plain
rice and nothing else
further down the road we find an
abandoned house home to a group of
Moroccan migrants 18 year old Youssef
invites us in to see how they live the
hygienic conditions are poor they have
no running water to wash their clothes
these containers are what they use to
shower we wonder why Youssef stays here
in these conditions he says life and
Morocco was as bad as it is here but
after three years as an illegal alien he
can get an official residence permit in
Spain at night the Spanish Sea Rescue
Service saves 54 young men from
sub-saharan Africa the dream of a better
life is what brings them to Europe and
in this very moment everyone on board
believes they're going to achieve
exactly that
here in Germany restrictions on
reuniting refugee families proved to be
a major sticking point in talks on
forming a new coalition government a few
weeks ago this woman told us her story
we meet up with Jose ma de Mira after
her German lessons this is how her day
starts here in Berlin without her
children or her husband she tells us
about her escape from Syria it all
happened in 2015 she left her three
children behind that's what her husband
wanted now he's in prison in Syria she's
alone in Berlin and her children without
their parents in Syria back then I
decided to leave the country in the
hopes of helping my children by starting
anew and then bringing them here that
was my only goal he shows his pictures
of her children that's her son and two
daughters with their grandmother
Sebastian mu helps her deal with the
situation he's had a lot to do since
2016 that's when the German government
stopped refugees like Cosima from
reuniting with their families it was
supposed to only last for two years but
now the Conservatives want to extend the
suspension despot Deutsche treestand I
in fact us that simply means that
families are separated for years parents
are separated from their children that
spouses are separated for years for a
period of time that has no definable end
and this is very hard for families to
deal with it's catastrophic
wolf attack in the center ossama shows
us her favorite passage in the German
Constitution Article six the special
protection of marriage and family since
the telephone lines to Syria are
disrupted all she has our photos
sort on I'm sure phone I keep getting
photos of my children but that only
makes it worse because I can't
experience them firsthand her last hope
is German politics jose mahomes that
some day she'll be allowed to live a
life in safety together with her
children
coal mining in India has had disastrous
impact on both the environment and on
people but often it remains the only way
to earn a living
sorry motto is 17 years old she
scavengers in the coal mines of cheriya
her brother Shiv Kumar is just 9 the to
begin work at dawn every day it's
fraught with dangers the coal has to be
hacked out of exposed seams once
Shiv Kumar badly injured himself while
working the open coal pit is a hundred
and fifty meters deep
savithri makes four to five trips each
day she has to watch out for the police
who trace them away and confiscate the
coal guys name I don't have a choice I
have to do this work
my parents are illiterate they've worked
as labourers all their lives they can't
do anything else so I try to help them
by earning money I really don't like the
work my heart isn't in it a few hours of
work fetches the equivalent of three
euros that's more than what people earn
here as day laborers some 30,000 people
work as cold scavengers but they pay a
heavy price
burning raw coal releases toxic smoke
and gases causing widespread asthma and
respiratory illnesses in the area
charrier sits atop one of the world's
largest coal reserves the Tryg antek
open pits and deep mines here account
for a quarter of India's coal production
the resulting toxic emissions have
devastated the environment the coal
fires have destroyed houses and
triggered landslides Ashoka Thirlwall
has been campaigning for the rights of
illegal cold workers like savithri
he says India is being a huge human cost
in its - for coal this government just
doesn't bother so right now coal is very
important it is very important for their
development they've got to develop
massive cities
to show to the world that they are at
par with them and at the cost of these
people there's a huge amount of human
beings who are going to be deprived of
whatever even there's some of the other
eking out the living that will also go
savithri is determined to find a way out
of the coal mines scavenging also helps
pay for college she goes there every day
after work to ensure her dreams of
getting a good job don't go up in smoke
our last report takes us to Thailand
where diesel and petrol engines power
traffic on the rivers and canals go
electric says a German company planning
a silent revolution
they might be iconic but they can be
quite a nuisance as well on Bangkok's
canals and floating markets longtail
boats are not only a familiar sight but
a familiar sound as well
David hunter and his team want to change
that today they're trying to convince
the local authorities that going
electric has many upsides they've
brought one of their test motors along
after all proof of the pudding is in the
eating
most people's mind when they switch from
a combustion to an electric is how long
will my battery last but I think for for
for areas like this where you don't go
too fast an electric motor it can go all
day without recharging so I think once
people get to understand it and feel it
that anxiety they had before will
quickly be taken away before they can go
for an piece pin the conventional motor
needs to be removed then the much
lighter torque IDO engine is mounted to
the boat it only takes a few flicks of
the wrist mr. Tuan the local boatman
doesn't seem to trust the three
horsepower drive but the slim engine
provides all the thrust he needs and
this now you have like 10 kilometers
range after a few minutes initial
skepticism gives way
but like mine this motor definitely has
enough power and it's so easy to use you
just turn the handle Thailand's Tourism
Authority is already on board with the
new technology provided the investors
don't shy away from the costs at two
thousand euros the retail price for this
model is about ten times as much as a
comparable combustion engine it's peace
and tranquillity however is certainly
priceless
you